is it true
of course it's true that um that after
the fact you guys got your deals all the
new people and it was like they're gonna
pay you the least amount of money that
they legally can to be a principal cast
member but then after the fact and after
the movie came out they came to you and
said hey we're gonna give you guys
participation in the back end um okay so
i
don't know what everyone else's
discussions were because again my
situation was different i wasn't like
from the beginning i didn't know i was
an official
cast member so the the payments i were
receiving were just like
i wasn't sag yet so they just paid me a
certain amount every two weeks and as a
comedian i'm just stoked to
see it and i'm just stoked to be working
so to me it didn't seem like out of the
ordinary i also didn't have reps when i
i booked jackass on my own so like i
didn't have to cut anyone 20 or anything
so again like i was just stoked to be
working um at the end
when um
when we kept getting word that the movie
release was pushed back there was a
conversation were you on the call for
that one i don't think exactly i
remember when they they had
like uh one call for og cash
and one call yeah i'm sure um so yeah
there was a conversation with all of us
where
um
they announced that it wasn't going to
be october it was pushed to february
yeah and that was like man i mean after
like for us you guys are you guys are
all
it's okay when it comes out comes out
but for us new cast members i mean this
is like the beginning of the rest of our
careers of our lives like the pandemic
hits we need some good news and when
they came to us and told us it was gonna
be like another six months it was just
like oh my god what are we gonna do you
know it was so funny on our call
it was just the og guys and uh spike and
um tremaine
and like whoever's speaking like that's
the what the screen shows it was so
funny because uh
tremaine says like
they're pushing the release date to
february and and then all of a sudden
the screen turns into dave england going
yeah
and then the screen becomes me i'm like
dave what are you talking about i was
like
you know the the
the trailer is out yeah there's a big
buzz around it and this the second this
movie comes out it's old news and where
washed up has been no you're right it
actually ended up it that was the
beautiful part is in retrospect it ended
up working out in our favor
and so much better because there was so
much more promotion it like people felt
like you know
there was a buzz around the whole thing
and i was like as soon as it comes out
we're over like old news by by delaying
the release to
like you know months down the road we're
extending this period of time that we're
like hot [ __ ] that has a buzz around us
right and uh and then and then you see
spike he's like wow i never thought of
it that way and then you see tremaine i
need everybody to be on their best to be
yeah that's what i honestly think that's
the most
that
poopy's has six months more do not [ __ ]
this up no i mean honestly like it it
ended up working out um for all of us
and and it was like such a nice surprise
any extra information that we got about
you know financing for sure
so again like i'm just grateful and yeah
i mean i was i'm just stoked
i mean yeah i heard that it was like
after the fact after i think maybe even
after the movie came out and they said
like hey we're gonna we're gonna give
you guys participation in the background
that was before actually that was before
the movie came out but it was during
that call when they said they were gonna
push to keep us from not killing
ourselves um rachel's like wait what i
was like people were getting
participation points well i i just i
didn't i didn't i didn't i just was
stoked i just was stoked well i know and
i i just i bring that up because i was
personally
really impressed and happy to hear that
you know like
you know
over the years going back to the
beginning like you know
trying to get paid
like it wasn't a real easy thing yeah
and uh for them to offer that up to you
guys when they really didn't have to
like i i just wanted to uh to tell them
like guys that's [ __ ] cool of you and
i mean
of course like we've heard the stories
about how you know how it was before and
right like
it is different now and we are a new
cast and we we do have it different than
you guys and
in a sense of like how things are just
because we're the new generation and you
kind of like laid it down you know like
pave the path for us so you did it's
almost like being the first born you
know the second the baby kind of gets
you know treated a little bit better
um and so my experience has only been
positive
like throughout the whole thing i have
nothing bad to say
like about anything that happened not
that like you were implying that or
anything but it's i think in hollywood
it's so rare to have that experience
especially on an all-male cast right
being the only female you know well yeah
and and gender aside the reality is that
you know people would line up for miles
to be able to be in a jackass movie you
know like i get a lot of submission
tapes
you can argue that there's like
so
many people would want to be in a
jackass movie regardless of whether they
got paid that
it's almost like they don't have to pay
right to be in it well
that's totally like i mean coming from a
comedy place like we do a lot of stuff
for free in the beginning yeah and
that's what i'm saying like i was just
even shocked that i was even my name was
thrown in the hat for this because you
know i'm not a pro skater i don't have
that background my background is comedy
which is what you guys do so you know
like i still can't believe even to this
day that
i was able to be a part of it so i am
still very stoked on it and it's still
very cool to me and that i hope that i
hope that shine never dims you know for
sure no i think it won't you have a
great attitude thank you everyone's
super stoked and and uh
you know you you earned the spot i mean
everybody earned it and you know like i
said they didn't even have to
give you anything and and they did and i
was really impressed yeah so it's you
know and i yeah i i just feel
really good about the whole thing so i
think that clip was awesome but not as
awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what i've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions which is
out september 27th and if you pre-order
it right now you can get the autographed
copy so get on it man pre-order my book
it's not going to waste your time
because i'm proven dude new york times
bestseller my first book's five star
rated on amazon and i have no doubt this
one will be two so get the autographed
copy right now
by pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude